[Música]
solo otras mil personas pudieron ser
evacuadas de la ciudad ucraniana de
mariupol donde 160 mil ciudadanos
sobreviven en medio de los ataques y sin
acceso siquiera a agua potable más
temprano la cruz roja había denunciado
que no había garantías para evacuar a
los civiles a su vez en el puerto de
odessa se reportó un ataque con misiles
contra una zona residencial
un equipo de reporteros de france 24 fue
hasta la localidad de sal típica ubicada
al norte del jardín donde se vive la
devastación de la guerra numerosos
residentes se han visto forzados a huir
pero unos pocos continúan en lo que
alguna vez fueron sus hogares en medio
de los bombardeos
este 23 de mayo dejará de aplicarse en
eeuu el llamado título 42 una norma con
la que se expulsaba a migrantes
indocumentados bajo el argumento de la
pandemia cerca de 1.7 millones de
personas han sido expulsadas con esta
norma durante los últimos dos años
ampliamos desde washington
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en ucrania en el
sur se registró un ataque con misiles
sobre la ciudad de odessa en principio
el gobernador de la región indicó que
tres proyectiles impactaron una zona
residencial no obstante luego el
ejército ucraniano señaló que el ataque
fue repelido por la defensa antiaérea en
quien las autoridades informaron que
hicieron retroceder a las tropas rusas
al tiempo que se recuperó el control de
varias ciudades al norte de la capital y
en el este más temprano oficiales
informaron que 6 mil 266 personas fueron
evacuadas mediante corredores
humanitarios de ellas 3.000 pudieron
salir de la asediada ciudad de mariupol
hacia sap orilla a su vez la vice
primera ministra ucraniana denunció la
confiscación de dos toneladas de
suministros
desafortunadamente la ayuda humanitaria
fue capturada por los ocupantes eran 14
toneladas de comida y medicinas este es
el precio de los acuerdos este es el
precio de las garantías dadas al comité
internacional de la cruz roja de que los
corredores humanitarios estaban
garantizados y podrían funcionar estamos
negociando el regreso de los buses para
que los residentes de melitópol puedan
partir mañana hacia esa polilla voy y
gt2 oppolicia entretanto tres misiles
golpearon una golpearon una zona
residencial del puerto de odessa como lo
estábamos señalando al principio de esta
información el gobernador de la ciudad
no indicó cifras de heridos o fallecidos
por su parte en el nororiente en kharkiv
las fuerzas ucranianas han logrado
contener a las tropas rusas pero algunas
zonas de la ciudad siguen siendo objeto
de intensos ataques de artillería y
misiles de día y de noche catherine
there is strange romeo languages raf a
bit reporteros de nuestras cadenas
hermanas en inglés y francés nos
muestran la destrucción y cómo
sobreviven las personas que se
encuentran en la primera línea de fuego
al norte dejar kit de sal típica es una
zona desierta la artillería rusa
bombardeada esta zona residencial día y
noche
todos los habitantes han huido o casi
la foto
ritchie
solo algunos cuantos como luzmila han
decidido quedarse
su peso
el 23 de marzo un misil alcanzó su
edificio
otros nacimientos de la fiesta
expresiva
otros
esta familia ha huido a un lugar más
seguro pero vienen al barrio todos los
días por solidaridad
aquí
aquí la lluvia de bombardeos de rusia
salpica la vida cotidiana en heart que
ya se ha cobrado la vida de al menos 300
civiles
es
cada vez que hay una alerta luz mila de
75 años se refugia en el sótano que
comparte con su vecino sanya
acosta
muchísimas
luzmila era profesora de música lleva
cinco semanas encerrada en su refugio
por fin una tregua
el vecino aprovecha para llevarnos al
quinto piso
donde cayó el misil
sanya es de origen ruso
esta guerra entre hermanos los superados
werner sinn houston ingenio
nieto
de búsquedas y simplón ya somos europa
busca grandes gay mitchell usuario
seleccionar mala whatsapp para los
idiomas
es un tema
esta vez los disparos vienen del lado
ucraniano
los enfrentamientos continúan cerca de
jarquín en los últimos días las fuerzas
ucranianas afirmaron haber lanzado una
contraofensiva y haber logrado recuperar
parte del territorio al este la
presidenta del parlamento europeo robert
amén sola se reunió en kiev con el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
aseguró que brindará a ucrania la
asistencia que necesite para ganar la
guerra la jefa del parlamento aseguró
que europa está con ucrania y ayudará a
reconstruir sus pueblos y ciudades
cuando terminen las hostilidades
asimismo la funcionaria aseguró que la
asamblea apoyará a los esfuerzos de
ucrania para iniciar el proceso de
ingreso a la unión europea
ustedes son nosotros y nosotros somos
ustedes pero al mismo tiempo también
están luchando en nuestra guerra están
luchando por los principios
fundamentales que este continente ha
defendido durante tantos siglos
yo me vengo aquí con el mensaje de que
este es el momento de lo que haga falta
así que me gustaría asegurarme de que
tienen todo lo que necesitan en sus
manos para ganar esta guerra porque si
ustedes ganan el mundo gana dv
[Música]
el director general del organismo
internacional de energía atómica rafael
grossi anunció que dirigirá una misión
lo antes posible hasta la central
nuclear de chernóbil y señaló que los
niveles de radiación son normales la
información se conoce al tiempo que
ucrania indicó que las tropas rusas
abandonaron las instalaciones y músculos
confirmó el radio situation around the
plan la situación general de la
radiación alrededor de la planta es
bastante normal había un nivel de
radiación localizado relativamente alto
debido al movimiento de vehículos
pesados en el momento de la ocupación de
la planta y aparentemente podría haber
sido el caso de nuevo en la salida así
que hemos oído hablar de la posibilidad
de que algún personal esté contaminado
pero no tenemos ninguna confirmación al
respecto
en república democrática del congo los
rebeldes del grupo armado m 23
anunciaron un alto el fuego unilateral
tras días de intensos combates contra el
ejército congoleño en el noreste del
país en un comunicado la organización
asegura que busca el inicio de un
diálogo con las autoridades para que se
produzca una resolución pacífica de la
crisis la información se conoce luego de
que los rebeldes empezarán a retirarse
el jueves de zonas que habían ocupado en
el norte desde el pasado lunes no queden
sólo unos días fuerzo unas 46.000
personas a abandonar la zona
vamos ahora está eeuu donde a partir del
23 de mayo dejará de estar vigente el
polémico título 42 una normativa con la
que las autoridades migratorias
expulsaron alrededor de 1.7 millones de
indocumentados
argumentando un riesgo a la seguridad
sanitaria por la pandemia de kobe 19
funcionarios del gobierno han señalado
que la administración está coordinando
planes ante un posible aumento en la
llegada de inmigrantes conectamos con
cristóbal vázquez él es corresponsable
france24 en la capital estadounidense
cristóbal qué efecto tiene esta medida a
nivel migratorio y político en eeuu
si la medida fue anunciada por el centro
de control y prevención de enfermedades
una medida que había sido impuesta por
donald trump y que no le permitía o que
le daba la autoridad a la patrulla
fronteriza de devolver a las personas de
las familias que cruzaban la frontera de
forma indocumentada con el pretexto de
sanidad pública así entonces una vez sea
levantada esta medida los solicitantes
el día cielo en eeuu podrán esperar en
eeuu la decisión migratoria esto es un
periodo más o menos de dos años que
estos inmigrantes
se les resuelva entonces la situación y
pueden quedarse en este país los efectos
que tiene esta medida es precisamente
estas olas de migrantes que tanto el
departamento de seguridad nacional como
otros organismos expertos en inmigración
esperan que empiece a ocurrir se calcula
de hecho que 18 mil personas al día
empezarán a llegar a la frontera y
frente a eso ya el gobierno nacional
está tomando medidas está enviando gente
y está empezando a habilitar centros de
inclusión de inmigrantes en las zonas
fronterizas esto va a ser sin duda una
herramienta electoral de los
republicanos que van a seguir
argumentando que los demócratas y la
administración de job aid él no está
protegiendo las fronteras sobre todo de
cara a la elección del congreso de este
año bueno hay otro tema que es noticia
en eeuu es que la cámara baja aprobó una
iniciativa para que los estados
establezcan sus propias políticas sobre
la marihuana que posibilidad real hay de
que la medida pase en el congreso
si la cámara de representantes la aprobó
con 220 votos a favor 204 en contra muy
en línea con la votación partidista pero
todavía no está decidida si esta medida
esta medida que legaliza el consumo la
producción la distribución de la
marihuana a nivel federal vaya a pasar a
un voto en el senado el senado está
dividido en 51 votos a favor de los
demócratas 50 a favor de los
republicanos y es muy difícil que pase
sin embargo la casa blanca está diciendo
que apoya a cualquier acuerdo que haya
en favor de esta legislación cristóbal a
usted muchas gracias por esta ampliación
en otras noticias este sábado 2 de abril
se cumplen 40 años del inicio de la
guerra de las malvinas
los argentinos continúan reclamando sus
derechos de soberanía lo que reinó
unido- responde que no hay nada que
discutir
se cumplen 40 años de la guerra entre
argentina y reino unido por las malvinas
argentinas aún reclama sus derechos
sobre los más de 12 mil kilómetros de
territorio que conforman el archipiélago
para que una política de estado una
posición del estado argentino ante el
tema que es justamente el reclamo de
soberanía eso no es algo que ningún
gobierno haya claudicado
sino
bloqueado lo que cambió es la forma de
y aproximarse a la guerra inició el 2 de
abril y duró tan sólo 74 días
participaron 23 mil combatientes
argentinos que carecían de suministros
básicos frente a los 26.000 del reino
unido- bien equipados se desplegaron 216
aviones y 38 buques argentinos contra
117 aviones y 111 buques del reino unido
los enfrentamientos dejaron 649 muertos
argentinos y 255 del reino unido la
guerra dejó decenas de denuncias de
torturas y humillaciones ejecutadas en
contra de los soldados argentinos por
parte de mandos superiores así como el
olvido del estado y la población a los
soldados se les hizo más difícil porque
la sociedad éste los negaba la mayoría
no conseguía trabajo y eso fue lo
difícil después de volver a encontrarte
con que la sociedad te rechazaba o te
ignoraba reino unido- no volvió a
acceder a negociaciones sobre la
soberanía de las islas
y se realizó en doha el sorteo del
campeonato mundial de fútbol qatar 2022
que definió los grupos de la primera
ronda del certamen que se iniciará el 21
de noviembre el anfitrión qatar debutará
contra ecuador que salió sorteado como
segundo del grupo a que completan
senegal y países bajos enelvén jugarán
inglaterra irán eeuu y el ganador del
playoff europeo reprogramado para junio
debido a la guerra en ucrania galés ya
está clasificado para ese playoff y
espera por el triunfador de escocia y
ucrania la llave se incluye a argentina
arabia saudita méxico y polonia y en la
de quedó ubicado el campeón vigente
francia que debutará contra el ganador
de la repesca entre perú y el vencedor
de la zona asia oceanía dinamarca y
túnez completan ese grupo
españa es cabeza de serie del grupo
donde jugarán el vencedor de la repesca
entre oceanía y costa rica por la
concacaf además de alemania y japón- la
llave f incluye a bélgica canadá a
marruecos y croacia
lage a brasil serbia suiza y cameron y
la h a portugal gana uruguay y corea del
sur
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
noticias a ustedes gracias por
acompañarnos en esta jornada informativa
continúen con nosotros en france 24
[Música]